You know, this is the message of Tolkien
and The Lord of the Rings. It's not that
well, you know, a hobbit is such a
good-natured person that they can hold
the ring. No, nobody can hold the ring.
Nobody can be entrusted with that much
power, but that's what they all want.
And that's what the system is built
around. This the whole corporatist
system is about creating control and
then extracting rent from that control.
It is not about adding value and the
differential between the value add and
the price being your profit margin. We
should we should call this cabal of
people the Nazgûl.
Cuz they're these clingy wraiths that
want to
run everything, but their own influence
has corrupted themselves first and
foremost. That's pretty much what they
are. In fact, that is what they will be
from this day forth, the Nazgûl. Um
>> The Nazgûl. There's like nine of them
and they're all creeps.
Yeah.